and you stop stealing my look what the
[ __ ] yeah
yeah you guys are about to go you guys
are about to go to a time share together
oh [ __ ] all right we got a couple more
then we got to get out of here
where is jake
okay
well he's not going to be classy i can
tell you that right now
what's up are you wearing a tie-dye
hoodie
my [ __ ] dude
i've never heard anybody yeah i'm a
tie-dye guy
[Laughter]
it's kind of my [ __ ] thing it's my
personality tie-dye guy
are you a time traveler or something
like that
oh jake's going to kill us after the
show thank you very much
[Laughter]
jake's question is a real i've never
thought of this after all the [ __ ]
times we've done that i've never thought
of this how many cell phone numbers have
you had
that sounds like a guy running from
something
how many have you had that's what i want
to know
[Music]
yeah delete them all you don't need
dylan
you're not a buddy that's called a drug
dealer okay
he is not your friend he's trying to
hurt you
delete his numbers and put the [ __ ]
tie-dye shirt away
all right we gotta we got two more here
the next one is uh where's andrew
right here how are you doing buddy oh i
think i know you maybe
i don't know he's like i don't know now
you're playing cool like i don't [ __ ]
know you [ __ ] hanging out to draw you
jerk
jerk-off
i never [ __ ] met you dude
i'm with tie-dye guy
[ __ ] hang me out the drive
i know that's what i'm saying i [ __ ]
know who you are don't play cool in
front of all these people
and you stop stealing my look what the
[ __ ] yeah
yeah you guys are about to go you guys
are about to go to a time share together
you'll be hearing from my lawyer
andrew uh he goes how long is how long
is acceptable to have a toilet which
requires you to remove the tank cover to
pull the little lever in order to flush
well if you ask my mother it's 25 years
he's got to jiggle it jiggle a little
bit
take the top off jiggle it you'll be all
right he said his answer was 10 business
days
that's a [ __ ] gentleman give andrew a
[ __ ] round of applause yeah
he likes to take it easy on the weekends
i like that
he's like well monday was a bank holiday
so
technically we bought ourselves another
13 days technically if you think about
it
and it's already what four o'clock now
so we got like 15 16 days
uh all right this next one's from kashan
over here what's up buddy how are you
are you here with myself i drove from
atlanta
what
how long is it i don't even that could
be an hour or 20 minutes i have no idea
what four hours but clap it up for
kashan yeah
and clap it up for google maps everybody
thank you guys
it's about three and a half with traffic
to be honest yeah i also his girl was
like it's four he's like three and i can
make it three and a half
[ __ ] three and a half five [ __ ]
id22 is open making
she's you know what i mean
do you do you have one of these kishon
do you use a windshield heat shade in
your car
are you a time traveler what the [ __ ]
man
what kind of car do you have
ah
if you have like a ferrari like yeah we
got to protect the leather
what year is the civic
[Music]
does it have a windshield
[Laughter]
guys you've been absolutely [ __ ]
fantastic thank you so much everybody
get home safe we appreciate you give
yourselves a big round of applause thank
you
you guys have been amazing we'll see you
soon thank you so much